قال دونالد ترامب إن المملكة العربية السعودية
لن تستمر أسبوعين بدون
دعم الولايات المتحدة ، إجابتك
على ذلك بصفتك سفيرًا سابقًا لدى الولايات
المتحدة ، وكذلك هل تعتقد الرياض أن لديها
واشنطن ودونالد ترامب على
برميل وتبرر التورية عندما  يتعلق
الأمر بجعل أمريكا عظيمة مرة أخرى ،
وسعر النفط الذي تعلم أن جيران المملكة العربية السعودية
يعتبرون أنفسهم في
وضع يسمح لهم بامتلاك أي شخص
فوق برميل في أي قضية نعمل من
خلال التشاور سواء كان ذلك
مع الولايات المتحدة أو مع غيرها.
البلدان ونأمل أن نتوصل إلى
توافق في الآراء بشأن المنافع المتبادلة وما إلى ذلك ،
لكنك تعلم أن المثل الأعلى السعودي
إذا شئت قد استمر لمدة ثلاثة
قرون الآن فيما يتعلق بالبقاء على قيد الحياة ،
ولا أعتقد خلال تلك
القرون أننا اعتمدنا على
حسن النية الأمريكية  ومع ذلك ، لا ننسى أبدًا أن
أمريكا وقفت معنا عندما
غزا صدام حسين الكويت ، وأن أمريكا قدمت
الأرواح لدعم المملكة العربية السعودية ،
وهذا موضع تقدير كبير ونذكره.
هربنا وسنظل عاملاً تاريخيًا ،
لكننا وقفنا أيضًا إلى جانب أمريكا
في الوقت الذي كانت فيه أمريكا مكروهة كثيرًا
في الشرق الأوسط في الخمسينيات
والسبعينيات من القرن الماضي ، ومع ذلك فقد تمسكنا بأمريكا
وتحملنا عبء تلك الصداقة مع
أمريكا من خلال  الهجمات من القوات المعادية للولايات المتحدة
في الشرق الأوسط ، لذا فقد كان الأمر
يتعلق بتاريخ من الاحترام المتبادل المنفعة المتبادلة